I am joined by my incredible date Rossy Ross Matthews.
(Ross laughs)
(audience cheers)
I mean you really are all a girl could ever dream for.
Oh oh.
No I'm not.
(Nischelle and Kevin laugh)
(audience laughs)
Well just not in that department,
and by the way that's why this is gonna last.
That's why it works right?
(hosts laugh)
I'm also joined by anyone else's dream date as well.
Our cohost for the hour Nischelle Turner and Kevin Frazier.
(audience cheers)
Hello.
(audience claps)
He's a dream date every once in a while.
(Ross laughs)
All right well it's time for us to dive
into this year's nominations.
Now let's check out the first category.
Here are the nominations for limited series.
Okay yeah the nominations for
limited series is, "I May Destroy You",
"Mare of Easttown", "The Queen's Gambit",
(audience cheers)
So good.
"The Underground Railroad" which is one of my favorite
Yes.
this year, and "WandaVision",
so innovative.
Oh people love WandaVision
So innovative
Innovative.
Wow.
Uh huh what do you thinks gonna win?
Well this one, this could be tough
because you heard the applause for Queen's Gambit, right?
(audience cheers)
Hands down the best.
But I think the industry loved
Mare of Easttown so much,
and loved what Kate Winslet did so much,
I think that, that could supplant Queen's Gambit.
Yeah.
I completely agree.
Queen's Gambit wins.
Okay.
I'm here to save y'all the angst, Queen's Gambit wins.
Alright.
We'll have to wait to find out.
And you know we like to turn
to our audience to take polls, let's see who they predicted.
Oh wow WandaVision.
WandaVision.
Innovative TV.
Marvel came to television,
It was beyond yeah.
Yeah.
It was different, it was exciting,
We got the origin story of Wanda and Vision.
Kevin [Yes]
So great.
Innovative.
Yeah, absolutely.
Alright well let's talk comedy.
Here are the nominations for comedy series of the year.
Kevin what are your thoughts?
Well the broadcast network nominee, "Black-ish",
Yes.
"Cobra Kai" which was fun,
and innovative and everyone's child watch,
every teenager, and I got sucked into it.
"Hacks" snuck up on me like nobody's business.
(audience cheers)
So good.
Jean Smart, Jean Smart, Jean Smart.
"The Flight Attendant", which oh my God Kaley Cuoco,
Loved it loved it.
And Rosie Perez we bow down to you.
"The Kominsky Method", "Ted Lasso", and,
"Pen15" of course.
Drew, she's obsessed.
"Emily in Paris", oh and I don't want to forget
Emily in Paris.
Oh I loved Emily in Paris
You know, there's a lot of talk that, you know,
this was originally Ted Lasso's to win
and all the hype was around Ted Lasso,
and I still feel that they have enough steam.
I still think, yeah.
A lot of people think, that Hacks could sneak in.
I do want to say that years later,
we're going to look back and we're going to say wow,
Black-ish should have got a little more love
Absolutely.
Since 2015, 25 nominations.
They've won once for hair.
It is an innovative show that has changed
the face of broadcast TV.
Changed the conversations
we're having at home, yeah.
(audience cheers)
I think you're right,
it is time to honor Black-ish.
And this is its last season.
So would love to see the show go out with a win,
they deserve it.
This is Ted Lasso's year, it is Ted Lasso's.
You're right.
(audience cheers)
Alright well, let's hear what our followers predicted.
Ted Lasso?
And Emily in Paris.
Ted Lasso,
or Emily in Paris.
Ted Lasso barely
edging Emily in Paris
[Nischelle] Wow.
Wow.
Huh, interesting.
That's Interesting.
Alright, now it's time to look
at lead actress in a comedy series in a show.
Alright.
So Tracee Ellis Ross is nominated for "Black-ish",
we just talked about them as well,
(audience cheers)
Allison Janney for "Mom",
we love her.
Jean Smart,
(cheers continue)
that's all we've been talking about, Jean Smart,
Jean Smart, Jean Smart for "Hacks".
Aidy Bryant for "Shrill",
(audience claps)
and then Kaley Cuoco for "The Flight Attendant".
And I have to tell you guys,
so word on the street is that this could be
coming down to a two woman race
between Jean Smart for "Hacks",
and Kaley Cuoco for The "Flight Attendant".
Why is The Flight Attendant a comedy?
Have you seen it?
I've seen it, I loved it.
It's hilariously, ridiculously,
absurdly yummy and crazy.
(Nischelle laughs)
[Ross] I laughed out loud.
Yes me too.
I thought it was,
one of the best series of the year,
but I didn't think it was a comedy.
I looked at it and I was like, it's a mystery.
Maybe you could call it a dra-medy,
but I think it was comedic.
I think it was extremely comedic.
Well in the industry a lot of the times,
they call it a dark comedy,
Yes.
which is one of the hardest genres to be successful.
Please take it from me as a producer.
They don't work most of the time.
A dark comedy is something people like, grapple with.
I don't know why, but they do.
That's real.
They do,
and I'll tell you what I don't grapple with,
Jean Smart in "Hacks".
They think it's hers.
I think it has to be hers, you know,
she created this character that is so layered, hilarious,
and heartbreaking at the same time.
It is a masterclass performance in "Hacks".
She is having a moment.
Now let's see who our followers predict will win.
Who it is, who do we have?
Jean Smart at 25%.
25%.
They're on the money.
I think so too.
You do have a really smart audience.
You got a super smart audience.
I'm telling you they have a crystal ball, it is freaky
(laughing)
I can't wait to see if their predictions come true.
We have to take a quick break,
but when we come back we are diving
into the most anticipated categories of the 2021 Emmys.
That's right, we're talking all things drama.
(upbeat music)